valide qu'on se connaît très très bien
tout début on va avoir besoin d'une
corbeille
quand vous entendez la corbeille à
coupable pour quatre notamment une fois
n'est la corbeille alors oui on me l'a
donc à une corbeille
c'est très simple ian thorpe corbeil ici
malik d'accord on connaît beaucoup
beaucoup de choses
toi sur moi moi sur toi il ya des
bouquins d'ici ce qu'on a vraiment envie
de faire ça oui
malick c'est très simple tu vas dire
près de moi ça vient et à côté de moi
malik
ici il y a des poux câble sur malik
bentalha et ici la dépouille cap sur moi
donc des choses qu'on connaît et que tu
a révélé à la production tu vas prendre
à chaque fois un papier tu va le mettre
en boule est si tu leur antre ça sera
dans la boue ce sera dans la poubelle
terminé on n'en parle pas
malheureusement s'il ne rentre pas on
lira l'apu cave à vin tous les
téléspectateurs
d'accord je vais démarrer alors ben toi
tu prends celle-ci puisque celle etienne
en fait et moi je sais que ça aussi
puisque moi je vais jeter les mêmes
alors attention on la met en bout leur
âge est bon alors si je la mets on
oubliera cette picarde sombre très bien
d'accord attention d'abord c'est la même
tranquille
l'affrontement
moi je les lui je visais biens-fonds ah
ouais j'suis pas du tout que cette peau
cap sur thur mois donc la mienne tulle
alliera c'est sûr regardez bien la cible
vers la cible alors il m'a dit gwendal a
battu price est vrai que c'est pas
tranquille tu vois je vais lire la pou
kft concernant nos m'attend pourquoi
c'est comme ça non c'est un chiffon me
ou enfin la donne à la première fois que
malik bentalha a pris l'avion il avait
20 ans et se rendait au marrakech du
rire il était terrorisé il a pleurniché
pendant tout le vol
aulas et weeds a priori non mais j'ai
senti la première fois l'avion mais jure
c'est vrai qu'en panique non mais en
plus c'est la ram j'adore je les
embrasse mais c'est la ram quoi c'est
énorme c'est la ram c'est que quand même
des turbulences tu peux entendre le
pilote prier
cyril a déjà envoyé par sms je suis peu
tu pues toujours autant de la gueule au
président emmanuel macron qu'il a sorti
cette histoire
babin je crois c'est qu'il est moi c'est
vous oui absolue alors allez-y raccorder
jamais écouté comme vous avez en vous en
voyez souvent des textos à vos amis très
sympathique
vous étiez en discussion avec
apparemment quelqu'un que vous
connaissiez mais comme vous avez deux
temps en temps des nouvelles du
président ça s'est un peu chevauchées et
pensons répondre à cette personne tu
peux toujours de la gueule c'est le
président m'a conquis arts au dessus
mais de facto mais si je le sais
authentique et il a répondu pardon pour
l'interrogation mais non mais non
maintenant il faudrait vous de quoi vous
avez colisée alors il alors du pardon
pointe oui bien sûr vous pardon pour la
grèce mais ce que c'est vrai ou pas
alors qu'il avait répondu je sais je
vais vous dire du mal gré la vérité qui
vous a raconté ça jean rachid je rachète
alors je vous dis j'ai ensuite ça fait
des semaines qu'ils se foutent votre
gueule à vous raconter des fausses
poucave alors attention c'est la main
celle là c'est sûr à oued souf lémanique
tranquille
vas-y ballet malik bentalha malik
bentalha ah bah merde
voici ces termes aux plus jeunes maliki
était le petit voyou du village
il passait ses journées à voler des
cartes dragon ball z au bureau de tabac
pour les revendre à l'école comme vous
mais qu'est ce qu'une bonne sanaa mais
sans hurler lâchez moi bordel il faisait
ça fait bien rire j'ai suivi ma passion
play mois baboulenne
non mais oui ça m'est arrivé mais j'ai
tout rembourser quand vous êtes tout
remboursé de rembourser quand on regarde
et behzad ya deux semaines
[Rires]
il est très serein il lycée pucca va
rentrer à sanaa je vais la mettre de
lancer sur aller celle là je ne vois pas
du tout cela je veux pas du tout qu'elle
passe
ayala vous la tête à tout ça va ils sont
dans le timing sur les bruitages en tout
cas où là
tu as le choix entre les tuent les i
non pas ceux là sont vraiment elles sont
vraies ok j'ai un train de temps
brouillé pour faire le nid l'autre prend
la pire pas la pire à pied d'accord
attendant l'autre hôte l'hôtel hôtel à
redire ma poubelle est la nôtre et là
d'accord avec toi de lui faisait des
plus cave laïque
ouais on est sur des fous cavés
sympathique ah oui là ben rhodes qui
écrit c'est lui qui paye à sallèles et
pas mal la confirmation des croyez quoi
ça c'est quoi cyril baisse son pantalon
pendant les réunions au bureau pour être
plus à l'aise ouais c'est vrai que c'est
vrai c'est vrai ce n'est pas dans une
rigolade en fait c'est à l'événement
mais nous et c'est ça j'étais vraiment
value n'est pas le temps d'affichage je
vous jure c'est vrai j'ai enlevé mon
pantalon qui dit vrai les gars
joaillerie comme en flandre et
financière c'est de la compta et locales
sont quand même non oui ben military
sales à aller la chercher s'il vous
plaît merci malik bentalha